it is a first in u.s history and it's
not a good one the national debt of the
united states has exceeded 30 trillion
dollars for the very first time
figures released by the department of
the treasury show the overall debt
climbed to 30.1 trillion dollars at the
end of january that's seven trillion
dollars higher than the figure just a
year ago the coronavirus pandemic
demanded binge borrowing by congress to
finance its coven 19 rescue plan however
economists also point to the trump
administration's 1.5 trillion dollar tax
cut as a major catalyst in running up
the national
debt
all right i'm joined here in the studio
now by my colleague steven beardsley
from dw business i mean all we have to
do is look at the numbers here so let me
make 30 plus 12 zeros stephen i mean
this is truly astronomical
so i mean we can't even relate to it how
does this number though what does it
tell us about the health of the us
economy i mean let's keep it in
perspective right i mean it is a nice
big fat round number but at the same
time it doesn't tell you that much by
itself it give you an example a home
loan for a hundred thousand or let's say
two hundred thousand dollars right
that's more expensive for someone who
earns maybe thirty thousand dollars in a
year than someone who earns one hundred
thousand dollars so we have to look
really at gdp in this case what is that
compared to debt that is higher than it
has been in recent years uh at the end
of fiscal year 2021 the congressional
budget office saying it was around 100
percent exceeded actually 100 percent um
and that projections are that by 2031 it
could be 107 that would actually eclipse
its high just after world war ii when
america was was cleaning up when it was
uh going through basically a big um
basically dealing with war debts right
um so you know this is controversial at
the same time there are countries that
have higher uh debt to gdp ratios look
at japan for example it also controls
its own currency so there's been a lot
of readjustment about how we should look
at debt especially for countries that
control their own currency and the us is
the world's biggest economy and when
we're talking about the politics of
driving up the debt i mean this is a
bipartisan
disaster if you will
yeah you mentioned the trump tax cuts
there's no doubt about that uh democrats
in recent years because of the pandemic
they would say have been spending quite
heavily republicans would counter that
they've gone beyond their mandate to
improve the economy they've done a
little too much social spending uh
interestingly if you look back you know
back to let's say right after the reagan
years where there was a big deficit that
greeted george h.w bush upon his arrival
he you know went uh to the democrats and
together they created concessions they
created compromises and um he raised
taxes despite promising not to do that
um and they managed to work out that
deficit and bring the debt down a little
bit and um that was something that we
actually haven't really seen in the same
measure in decades since you know for
conservatives uh tax hikes uh that's
anathema that's something that is not
politically possible george h.w h.w bush
lost the next election right we should
mention because he was pummeled for
going back on that promise
no new taxes right um and at the same
time you know democrats are very
hesitant to hesitate to rein in spending
on social services the ones that the
republicans often pummel whether it's
social security whether it's medicare
medicaid so there is this reluctance
we've seen that kind of division in
recent years and it we see it here with
the debt levels as well and we know
people are complaining about the prices
they see at the grocery store now
inflation now at rates we haven't seen
since the early 80s the u.s fed says it
wants to start raising interest rates as
early as next
month what is that going to mean for the
debt
yeah i mean honestly inflation actually
would help pay off the debt more but it
would be terrible for people so no one
really is going to pursue that route we
want to pull down inflation
interest rates will also increase the
amount of debt service right that will
make that interest uh that that interest
more expensive to pay off
so the question is you know how are you
going to do that what's going to happen
now some would say that as long as u.s
growth is well above the interest rates
then naturally things are going to come
down the only problem is that really
that still taxes those who have assets
for example those who are saving so in a
way the country pays off its debt
through attacks on those on the wealth
of normal americans so you know there's
criticisms of both side you know it's
not a one-to-one ratio that if the
country is growing more than the
interest rates that it's going to be
able to pay that off so there there is
push back on this idea let me ask you
about the other big economic story today
and that is the great resignation it's
not slowing down we got numbers out um
today for december more than four
million americans quit their jobs um in
december for 2021 a total of more than
40 million people said take this job and
shove it that's never happened in the us
before either i mean the u.s is a very
flexible job market it's very different
from here in germany or in europe for
example so people have always left and
come back to jobs very easily but yeah
we're seeing something that is very
different than normal um you know what
we saw was a lot of people who left they
had to work at home they maybe left
precarious jobs jobs they didn't like
kovid shook things up and now they're
not coming back we have to remember
there is still a virus in the u.s so
there are some people who don't want to
come back maybe afraid of coming back
but there obviously has been a
reevaluation by others there are plenty
who maybe on the margins they found that
they could afford to not have to work
maybe they were close to retirement
maybe they weren't the breadwinner in
their family and they found that they
didn't actually have to be at work um or
maybe there are others who wanted to try
something different they found that
coveted gave them a chance to reset and
they weren't scared to maybe go in a
different path so it's hard to say what
exactly is going on but with the
flexible job market like you have in the
u.s one that's so fluid
it is easier to come back so we still
might see something happen
especially after you know this virus is
finally when that happens if that
happens and we know that teachers have
been quitting in alarming numbers and
also i can imagine that a lot of people
who have been working from home
have discovered like like you were just
describing you know why do i need to sit
in traffic jams anymore right i mean
it's the work-life balance that thanks
to the coronavirus now i've realized i
want to live better than i did before
yeah for sure i mean um you know
recruiters for example have been saying
in recent years that more and more
younger generations of workers more
younger workers in these younger
generations their value assessment when
it comes to work and what they want out
of it is shifting fundamentally it's not
as much about the paycheck it's not as
much about the position but it's about
the work-life balance as you said and
covet has given workers even more reason
to see firsthand what it's like if they
spend more time at home if they don't
have to sit in traffic commutes are a
big thing in the u.s as both you and i
know so that's no small thing when it
comes to quality of life so if workers
are preferring better quality of life
then they're giving a total reassessment
in general to what they may be doing as
their profession makes you feel lucky
when you can take a bike to work
absolutely exactly
stephen beardsley thank you as always